[inaudible]
I told you at the
beginning of the class that
I started working on this material.
Okay.
Partly because I was interested in why.
People were so inclined to,
to go to any lengths to
protect their belief systems.
I wanted to understand,
and I knew that those
were systems of value,
right?
That that belief system is something that
enables you to ascribe value to things
so that so that you can act in the world
towards things in a way from things,
roughly speaking,
and
I've already made a case to you,
that
belief systems regulate
people's own emotions,
but not,
not as a consequence of
decreasing their death,
anxiety or anything like that,
or even directly decreasing their,
their threat sensitivity or uncertainty,
but more specifically by helping them
orient themselves in the world so that
what they do matches what they
want in the social environment.
And it's an important set of distinctions
because the emotional control that
belief systems allow is mediated by
success in the social environment.
That's the crucial thing.
It's not,
it's not directly.
It's not as if you're holding a belief
system and that's directly inhibiting
somehow your emotional responsivity.
It's more that you share.
You have a motive orienting yourself
in the world so that other people can
understand what you're up to so that
you can cooperate and compete with them
without conflict and the fact that you
can do that without conflict and maybe
even with cooperation,
that's what regulates your emotion.
So it's not only the fact of
the beliefs belief system,
it's the fact that it's shared
with everyone else and so
people are willing to defend their belief
systems because they're defending the
territorial structure that enables them to
make sense of the world and then to
act out making sense of the world with
everyone else around them.
Now then the question arises,
what if two different groups of
people have different belief systems?
What do you do in a situation like that?
And one answer is
you capitulate.
Another answer is that you fight.
Another answer might be that you come to
some consensus about how the difference
between those different belief systems
might be mediated so that you can inhabit
the same territory without
subordination or without conflict.
But if you're going to come
together and an agreement,
you can't do that simply by abandoning
the belief system because the belief
system is what orients you in the world.
And so the negotiation is very
tricky and because of that,
it often ends up in
subordination or conflict.
Another question that might arise out of
that rat's nest of questions is if you
have belief system a and you have
belief system B and they're in conflict,
is there any principles that you can use
or any guidelines that you can use to
take the belief systems apart to under
to try to understand what might be of
central value in either of them or both
so that if you do bring them together or
even if one supersedes the other,
that there's some evidence that they're
predicated on principles that are
actually viable.
And of course that brings up the question
of what constitutes viable principles.
And I got interested in that
more predicted or question
because when the Cold
War was raging,
there were two ideological
systems set up in the world.
Roughly speaking.
There were of course more,
but we can simplify it for the sake
of argument down to two and one was
predicated on the communitarian principles
that were put forward by Marx and the
other was a consequence of,
you know the,
I would say western,
individualistic,
free market capitalist democracies,
roughly speaking.
And then you might ask yourself,
well were those only,
was that only a difference of opinion?
Right,
because that's the central question.
If it's just a difference of opinion,
if what's underneath
it is arbitrary then a,
it doesn't matter which
system wins roughly speaking
be,
there's no right and
wrong in the discussion,
right?
It's that that would be something that
would be more akin to a postmodern claim.
It's just group a puts
forward their claims to power
and Group B puts form their
claims power and they're both equally
valid and while have add are fundamentally
because there's no way of
of solving the problem.
But it struck me that that I didn't think
that we should leap to that conclusion
so rapidly.
And so I started to investigate.
I think I started to investigate
the substructure of Western thought,
not so much communist thought because I
thought of communism as an interloper on
the scene.
It was a system that wasn't devised and
formalized until the late 19 hundreds
late 18 hundreds and I didn't see it
as part of what you might describe as
organic development,
no mythologies,
so to speak,
at the basis of,
of the communist perspective.
And one of the things that's
very interesting is that
although those ideas were
roundly defeated by the
end of the 20th century,
they're making a comeback so rapidly
that it's almost unbelievable.
You know,
I got an email from a medical student
yesterday at the University of Toronto and
now they're the courses that
they have to take the mandatory,
these are social justice courses
include modules on equity and equity as
equality of outcome.
It they're pushing.
People are having the equality of outcome
notion pushed on them in mandatory
training and universities everywhere.
Again,
an equity isn't equality of opportunity.
It's equality of outcome.
You know,
that was the central dictum of the
Communist states in the 20th century.
It's like,
what the hell?
How,
how did we get back to that again already?
So,
and the idea being is if there isn't
absolute equality of outcome within an
organization,
that the thing is corrupt and needs
to be restructured from the bottom up.
And then the question of course,
is who decides that outcomes
are equal by what means?
And with what groups?
Cause you can,
you can produce an infinite number of
groups of people with equally validly in
some sense.
And you're never going to get equality
of outcome across the infinite number of
ways that you can parse
up society into groups.
It's not even technically possible
unless everyone has nothing.
So anyways,
these are obviously very powerful ideas.
And the mere fact that they killed 100
million people already are more in the
20th century.
It wasn't enough to put them to rest.